so wir machen wir weiter das ist
wirklich komisch ich habe davon wirklich
bis heute noch nie etwas gehört hat was
glaubt jetzt willkommen beim neuen video
ja leute jetzt wahrscheinlich schon
gehört wahrscheinlich schon an meiner
stimme ich bin ganz leicht angeschlagen
also nicht wie eigentlich schon ziemlich
erkältet aber auf jeden fall schon
wieder auf dem weg der besserung
deshalb sei sie heute morgen vor meinem
laptop und habe mir gedacht hey was
kannst du heute für ein video machen ich
würde jetzt nicht so gern irgendwas mega
aufwendiges machen wo ich da draußen
muss oder sonst was
deswegen habe ich geschaut was habt ihr
mit einer öfter mal geschickt was ich
denn mal wieder machen soll oder so ist
ja voll blasser außen oder liegt in der
irgendwie sich schon blass aus auf jeden
fall gab es von mir diese ganzen videos
zehn mädchen trends zehn jungs trennt
sich das ganze trendorientierte was
zieht man an und was ziehen nicht so
viele andere was findet generell meine
zuschauerschaft nicht so cool also der
sinn von diesem videos ist ja immer
anhand von eurer meinungen zu ermitteln
was ist gerade trendy und was eher nicht
oder was ist trendy aber sieht scheiße
aus sondern ist so hart sagen könnte und
er das letzte video dazu liegt schon
eine weile zurück ich glaube vier fünf
monaten war so ich habe euch aufs netz
gefragt wenn ihr mir da noch nicht folgt
auf jeden fall jetzt machen kurz
eingeblendet ihr habt jetzt fünf
sekunden zeit benutzer folgen 54 32 105
und jetzt machen wir weiter auf jeden
fall wären jetzt schon 2017 oder schon
länger 2017 was ist gerade so richtig
trendy was seht ihr oft was zieh dir
selber gerne an schickt es mir und die
dinge wo ich ausschließlich positive
rezension zu bekommen habe was halt
gerade so trendy ist vieles davon kannte
ich selber auch gar nicht das zeige ich
euch jetzt und wenn dann auch noch ein
paar haben wollt mit halt so trends die
vielleicht nicht so cool sind oder wie
viel halt geschrieben haben ja alex
guckt ihr dass man ist total scheiße aus
las man dann nach oben da dann gibt es
auch noch ich sehe das ja dann und ja
jetzt fangen wir an was jetzt in letzter
zeit wenig in den trend gekommen ist
sind diese hose ich bleibe ich das mal
kurz ein und zeigt euch hier ich weiß
gar nicht wie die genau heißen auf jeden
fall sehe ich das ziemlich offen wir
haben auch wirklich sehr sehr viele von
euch so ein foto geschickt wo er hat
gerade seine hose anhat
mädels jetzt also ich finde abgesehen
von diesem trend jetzt das aufgekündigt
megacool wollte ich einfach mal kurz
sagen also wenn du das siehst cooler
style keine augen wie die hosen heißen
sieht aber koloss also habe ich
natürlich auch öfters schon mal draußen
jetzt gesehen irgendwie wenn man da
jetzt gar nicht weiter drüber nachdenkt
dann fällt etwas gar nicht auf dass es
vor einem jahr oder so noch nicht so
trendy was auch wirklich sehr sehr viele
geschickt haben waren die schuhe und
zwar so wie es jetzt ist die frage seit
wann gibt es schon mehrere jahre da bin
ich mir ziemlich sicher ich werde aber
auch auf jeden fall mega ich habe mir
jetzt vor zwei monaten oder einmal
glaube ich mal so wenn es geholt weil
ich dachte erst die passen nicht zu mir
aber seitdem habe ich mir sofort noch
zwei paar gekauft also natürlich gibt es
schon länger ein oder haben viele
zugeschrieben ja alle auf meiner schule
oder alle girls und auch viele jungs
laufen mit weltruhm deswegen ich gehe
wirklich stark davon aus wenn es also
die marke west hat wirklich gerade so
einen boom weil es laufen echt viele
leute mit weltruhm nur es gibt heute
schon länger welt so leute was ich auch
mega witzig fand und zwar hat mir jemand
geschickt euch das bild kurz hier ein
diese bettwäsche also ich weiß nicht ob
das ein trend ist aber voll viele von
meinen freundinnen haben die auch und
ich dachte mir so ich habe diese
bettwäsche auch schon mal gesehen aber
das kann es eigentlich nicht in ein
video mit rein nehmen weil keine ahnung
als wenn jetzt so viele die gleiche
bettwäsche haben und dann öffne ich
immer mehr und mehr snaps und irgendwann
ist mir dann wieder diese verkaufen fall
noch jemand geschrieben hat hier auf
viele haben diese bettdecke und dann
habe ich einfach zwei selbst bekommen wo
es zufall einfach wieder genau diese
bettdecke oder diese bettwäsche was auch
immer drauf war
und irgendwie habe ich das gefühl sie
hat jeder faser ich habe eine ganz
normale weise aber ich glaube er hätte
ich so der bettwäsche wird mich der eine
oder andere der hier in mein zimmer
kommen doch etwas schief anschauen der
deswegen habe ich das mit ins kino
genommen ich habe mir erst gedacht hey
bettwäsche kannst jetzt sich in den
video tun muss um modetrends geht aber
wenn wirklich so viele diese bettwäsche
haben warum nicht so wir machen wir
weiter
das ist wirklich komisch ich habe davon
wirklich bis heute noch nie etwas gehört
dann habe ich euch heute aufgefordert
die ausstieg ein trend zu und viele
haben gesagt ja alex es ist nicht mehr
trainiert dass man möchte nur
freundinnen hosen hat mein mann hat
jetzt löcher auf hinten in der hose also
praktisch kann man dann den arsch sind
löcher am hohen dom soll denn dieser
jeans trend gefallen
ja das ist auch die frage warum nehme
ich das ins video
ich glaube würde ich das jetzt mit rein
invest irgendwie dumm weil es geht ja in
diesem video mädchen trends die jungs
ganz cool finden und ja ich denke es
also ich fand das schon ganz cool wäre
das trendy so ich glaube mit meiner
neuen kollektion kommt dann auch meine
hose raus die hinten löcher hat das wäre
dann die alex w s kropp jeans oder so wo
man auch ein trend der nicht selber
ermitteln habe ich kann ja mal sehen was
wir von vielen sachen viel gekauft und
wenn ich mir dann mal so den weibchen
angucke und sehe also hat den shop mit
meinen klamotten ich gehe mal kurz drauf
wir haben hier zum beispiel diesen
switching wie heißt der suite shirt mit
diesen streifen ärmeln das ist der
absolute renner
also streifen zum teil gerade irgendwie
auch in deswegen wenn ihr nicht wisst wo
ihr euer geld für ausgeben sollte weit -
curling dort kommen die beste
entscheidung eures lebens das hab ich
irgendwo schon mal gehört natürlich habe
ich auch gefühlte zwei milliarden mal
irgendwas von levi's zugeschickt
bekommen ehrlich wenn ich auf die straße
gehe ich sehe überall weil es könne
nicht so abziehen 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 natürlich das ist ein schönes motiv
aber irgendwie habe ich das schon so oft
gesehen deswegen kommt das jetzt nicht
vor und dass ich mich auch gefragt habe
warum schickt sie mir also fotos für
ihre augenbrauen zu gewalt sind und dann
habt ihr eine geantwortet sie meinte das
ist bei instagram filter aber ich finde
diesen filter nicht ich habe dann
einfach nicht aber das pastorin wie gar
nicht ein thema was ich dann aber mega
cool finde sind diese zöpfe da muss ich
auch erstmal ein bisschen recherchieren
wie den heißen und hab dann erfahren
dass sind die sogenannten box boxer
boxer schnitt zöpfe oder boxer boxer
zöpfe glaube ich zb dieses foto an oder
diese fotos megageil alter die sieht aus
wie von game of thrones also box hat für
sind echt cool aus dann könnte auch
immer sagen ja das sind boxer zöpfe wenn
du die scheiße findest dann können wir
gerne einen boxkampf machen und was ich
auch noch zweimal zugeschickt bekommen
hat war natürlich auch dieses match
schon vor aber das hatte ich schon
einmal vor einem halben jahren oder so
nur das gibt es jetzt auch als socken
das ist dann einfach keine hose mehr
leider sind socken
netzstrumpfhosen socken netzstrümpfen
nein aber nicht ganz einfach nur
netzstrümpfen sondern netzstrom sockel
mit schleife aber sieht auf jeden fall
ganz süßes aus deswegen habe ich das
aber mit reingenommen und er ja meist
selbst ist jetzt öffentlich deswegen
endet michalewitsch schickt bilder coole
trends zu egal ob jungs trends mädchen
trends trends die vielleicht nicht so
cool findet für einen zweiten partner
noch einen dritten instagram könnt ihr
natürlich auch gerne vorbeischauen
wir sehen uns dann eventuell schon
morgen wieder morgen kommt um 16 uhr ein
cooles video aus rein